you're talking to my neck it's an
excellent question action action welcome
back to glamour taste by me Josh Smith
and today we're joined by two queens are
basically everything Jennifer and Rhys
how are you so good so good now for me
this is the best uh black since Sonny
and Cher a great double act this show is
amazing plus for guys doing a Shamu and
one of the things about these characters
have really struck me is that they're
very public personas and everyone feels
like they're in their lives or in their
homes every single day aren't they and
then behind that especially your
character I mean you're going through a
whole emotional wealth of issues and
stuff and I feel like for both of you -
you're such iconic people and I feel
like everyone feels like they know you
to certain extent how do you navigate
that yourself in your own lives is that
quite difficult there's ways that I
related to Alex in terms of you it you
do find yourself I find myself at times
isolating a little bit more staying I
love being home home is very comfortable
safe space space but if you stay home -
for too long you will become isolated
and lose touch with what's going on in
the real world so that's something to
keep a very and I think that Alex's
character has kind of done that she sort
of lost touch in a way and is trying to
just survive what's going on with her
personally her child her relativity you
know what it means and relevance and
just staying like there because you guys
are both on different soldier knees at
the hustle they're on you
what's your own relationship with the
hustle been like how what have been the
most difficult times of hustling for you
guys would you say I definitely had a
hard time at the beach getting a job
getting arrested I was a waitress
forever but then yeah I don't been
pretty smooth in terms of fat though I
recently had to raise money for my new
company and that was a completely
different kind of hustle because people
don't care like
it doesn't mean that just because you've
had success in one area doesn't mean
that you have success in a different
areas so to go out to venture
capitalists and just pitch myself and
say believe in me and that was
challenging of course it is but what
like there's no gain without that pain
yeah right emotional and its
invulnerability vulnerability willing to
be wrong and people turn me down and it
it was I mean it's hard good air Georgie
let's name it later from that rejection
that's quite a hard thing to go if you
don't continue to put yourself out there
if your ego is bigger than then you're
will yeah you're you're gonna limit your
experiences so it was very humbling to
me but I thought if I don't try it I'll
always regret that I didn't try and
really own my own company um I didn't
want to be owned by other people and
it's been really great you know yes and
create the working environment you want
to grade which is such an amazing yeah
to be able to do my own culture right
because the culture that we grew up in
is broken mm-hmm and doesn't allow space
for women to be leaders it's such
amazing narrative to have these strong
powerful women right but for me I'm like
everyday women are strong powerful women
so when people come into interviews and
say gee guys what's it like painted
strong powerful women I'm like guys
they're strong powerful humans and it
always reduces the fact that it's not
the norm how do you feel about that
narrative I think it's interesting that
that's the that's the thought that
people have you know that it that is
it's not the norm that women are strong
and powerful we're all powerful human
beings because I might find me one who
isn't strong that's right but you guys
go through a lot yeah yeah for sure it's
all about you guys taking control of
that narrative in so many different ways
what has been taking control of the
narrative like for you and your own
lives would you say I think it's
honestly it's finding of my voice I
think it's also realizing that I have to
find my source out my own material
because the the the scripts aren't
written for the stories that I wanted to
tell I think Reese wanted shell
obviously so
was something that kind of dawned on me
you know ten years ago or whatever more
than that 15 was that oh yeah this has
got you've got we've got to take care of
this ourselves because there's nothing
out there that's that feels inspiring or
exciting and it takes a long time I mean
not it wasn't until recently that we
that it wasn't just something that was
you know deemed us hours in that suite
you're producing because say like find
your own voice is such a difficult thing
to do anyone there's any human being and
finds that quite difficult to do
sometimes what's that been like for you
guys like finding your inner voice and
staying true to where I'm normally
grateful for the women who have spoken
up and told their stories assault or
abuse or how negative their work
environments are because in a lot of
instances they had nothing to gain and
really culture change because those
people banded together and spoke out and
sometimes just spoke out as individuals
but that revelation really changed
history I think did it change you guys
as well I had all sorts of feelings I
was sad I was sad I was mortified I was
trying to play catch-up as to wait
what's happening and who is this too
aggressive you know they were it was
like loud really remember how loud it
was and the men were getting just like
booed and hissed all of a sudden it
didn't matter what man knew any man that
had a you know just an accusation okay
when you watch the first episode it's
kind of like they're waking up to a new
world isn't there yes and that's exactly
how we wanted to the tone of the show to
be which was it's just happened yeah and
how do we handle this what do we do
what's the crushing man new New World
Order yes it's a new normal and we've
got to read the playbook and figure out
what the new rules are yeah I'm
rewriting the rules as well
which is a difficult thing to do now one
thing I need you to ask you guys before
you whiz off you're busy girl yes we saw
for your whiz are now I know you love a
party
because I saw that thing where you wrote
on Twitter saying you're never too old
and it's never too late which I love
yeah now who's the biggest hype girl
here who's like you go and you type each
other yeah
all hive wait yeah she's a woman's yeah
you hate me I hate me too all the time
you had me I love that you're a high
base you hide me it's like no you
completely
you should put height beasts on your new
Instagram bio yes that's where you need
to put there right there
well you height B's thank you so much
piping up the world need more arm